an alien with a horse head the frog of
thunder a couple of mutants heroes from
the future and other universes even the
dc universe
when it comes to marvel comics thor
odinson isn't the only one who's been
worthy of wielding the hammer
first appearing in 1962's journey into
mystery number 83 thor odenson is
initially the alter ego of dr donald
blake who finds mjolnir and proves
worthy to wield it thor and blake can
switch places by smacking mjolnir on the
ground it's later revealed that blake is
a construct of thor's father odin and
while there are a few other attempts to
saddle thor with the secret identity for
the most part he exists solely as thor
even during periods when thor odinson
briefly loses his powers he never stays
on the sidelines for very long even
without mjolnir he refuses to be
anything but a hero at least make it a
challenge for me
when the ultimate thor is introduced in
2002's ultimates number four no one's
sure if he really is thor nick fury
tries to recruit him into the ultimates
while he's a far-left activist in norway
who has published self-help books and is
popular on lecture circuits he was also
institutionalized for over a year after
his revelation that he was the son of
odin it isn't until the second
ultimate's volume that his godhood is
confirmed the ultimate thor is one of
the many heroes lost when marvel's
ultimate line officially closed with
2015's ultimate end his unique version
of mjolnir remains though as this
half-hammer half axe appears in asgard
at the end of 2015's thor's mini-series
and has since had a significant impact
on the course of events in the prime
marvel universe
as a result of the 2014 line-wide
event's original sin thor odinson loses
his worthiness in that year's thor
number one a female thor takes up the
hammer and fills the void that odinson
leaves behind her identity was left a
mystery for a time but eventually thor's
former main squeeze jane foster is
revealed to be the new hammer wielder in
thor number eight
jane
jane then remains thor for four years in
2018's mighty thor number 705 she's
forced to sacrifice mjolnir in order to
defeat the monster mangok thereby losing
the power of thor
more recently in the conclusion to
2019's war of the realms event jane
replaces valkyrie in the ongoing series
valkyrie jane foster
walt simonson's run on thor remains one
of the most well-remembered stints in
marvel comics history that includes his
introduction of horse-faced hero beta
ray bill who proves himself worthy of
the power of thor
in 1983's thor number 337 thor
intercepts a spaceship at nick fury's
request but its pilot turns violent
during their clash bill lifts mjolnir
only seeking to use it against thor
they eventually work things out and odin
decrees that since bill has proven
himself worthy he and thor must fight
for mule near his possession bill wins
the fight but refuses to take the hammer
so instead odin has the dwarves of
nidavellir create a new hammer named
stormbreaker for bill
in 1978's thor number 276 cameraman
roger red norbill captures thor
odinson's belt of strength and iron
gloves allowing him to become a new thor
capable of wielding mjolnir the new
red-haired thor seems more villain than
hero at first but he eventually proves
himself worthy of the title when he
sacrifices himself to save asgard two
issues later and that isn't the end of
red norvel he earns a spot in valhalla
for his sacrifice and odin resurrects
him in thor number 478 to replace thor
whom odin feels is neglecting his duties
to asgard since then red has essentially
been in limbo as he was last seen in
1997's journey into mystery number 513
in the asgardian wars stretched across
1985's new mutants special edition
number one and x-men annual number 9
loki tempts storm from the x-men by
giving her what seems to be the power of
thor when her friends arrive on asgard
to save her loki's magic makes them all
appear as enemies loki crafts a powerful
hammer for aurora and she nearly kills
wolverine with its magic and gives hella
a run for her money eventually aurora
sees through loki's magic and
relinquishes her power knowing that
keeping it would mean being loki's
puppet despite this sacrifice the
asgardian wars isn't the last appearance
of this particular goddess of thunder as
she's shown to still have access to this
power in 2018's x-men gold number 26 you
know what happens to a toad when it's
struck by lightning the same thing that
happens to everything else
if you've ever wondered what thor would
look like in a dystopian future then
you'd better check out 1987's thor
number 384 in which dargo couture is
transformed into a much spikier version
of our hero in the 26th century a
massive corporation called core rules
over the earth dargo is a member of the
secretive cult of the hammer that
somehow manages to locate mjolnir though
he doesn't believe in stories of thunder
gods when loki uses the forces of core
to assault the cult
dargo grasps mjolnir's handle and proves
himself worthy dargo also appears again
a few more times including as a member
of the original thor core
at the very end of 1986's thor number
363 a disguised loki turns his
half-brother into a frog thor remains
froggy for a few issues thereby becoming
throgg frog of thunder then in 2009 a
new throg emerged in lockjaw and the pet
avengers number one we meet simon
walterson who's cursed by a witch and
becomes throgg full time he's become
kind of popular since then you can croak
fear into the hearts of your enemies as
throgg in lego marvel super heroes 2 and
he also has his own story in 2017's
mighty thor number 700. more recently
throgg kicked interstellar butt as the
tiniest member of the asgardians of the
galaxy and he also showed up very
briefly on the loki tv show
for a time thor maintained the secret
identity sigurd johnson whose closest
circle of friends included eric
masterson in 1989's thor number 408 thor
begs his father to save masterson's life
after he's fatally wounded by the
villain mongoose odin solves the problem
by using his magic to merge thor and
eric together when they're eventually
separated odin creates the mace thunder
strike for eric granting him abilities
comparable to thor's eric names himself
thunderstrike after the mace
unfortunately he ultimately makes the
mistake of using a weapon called the
blood axe as it possesses him with its
power in 1995's thunder strike number 24
he regains control of himself long
enough to make the ultimate sacrifice in
order to defeat the blood acts
a decade before jane foster proved
herself worthy there was thor girl her
real name is tareen an alien gifted with
cosmic powers whose coming was foretold
billions of years ago by an alien
sorcerer she uses her abilities to turn
herself into an asgardian goddess in
2001's thor number 33.
for a time she acts as thor odinson's
ally but she eventually loses most of
her power in battle with the demon
surter terrine then remains on the
periphery of the marvel universe she
becomes a part of the government's
initiative project during civil war and
even battles the hulk and his war bound
in the 2007 event world war hulk
she's last seen in a later event fear
itself during which she grows tired of
humanity and leaves earth for space ways
after the events of 2015's secret wars
the ultimate thor's version of mjolnir
appears in old asgard thor odinson
initially seems to want to retrieve the
weapon for himself in the miniseries
unworthy thor but he eventually decides
it isn't for him we learn in mighty thor
number 20 that ball stack the large
red-haired member of the warriors 3
takes up the hammer instead he then
becomes the war thor shortly after he's
traumatized when he fails to save a
group of children from a fire demon when
valstag tries and fails to stop the
monster man gog in 2017's mighty thor
number 701 the beast crushes the
ultimate version of mjolnir and leaves
volstagg bleeding and helpless
if you even think about betraying him
you'll kill me
evidently there will be a line
the third issue of civil war ends with a
bit of a shocker thor had been missing
and presumed dead but he appears on the
last page ready to do some damage in the
following issue he kills bill foster aka
goliath we later learn that this is not
thor but a cyborg clone and the mythic
warrior hercules crushes the clone's
head with his own hammer in civil war
number seven the clone later awakens in
2009's avengers the initiative number 21
and renames himself ragnarok he spends
some years as a villain recruited into
the villainous green goblins team of
dark avengers and then he eventually
joins the thunderbolts he was last seen
in 2013's dark avengers number 190 on a
mission on an alternate earth
after the death of eric masterson his
mace is left in the hands of the
avengers in 2010's thunder strike number
one captain america gives the maze to
eric's son kevin after using the weapon
to try to pry some civilians loose when
they're pinned under a car kevin
experiences the same transformation as
his late father after a short solo
series kevin joins the young avengers
academy heroes fighting alongside them
in the 2011 line-wide event fear itself
he then later joins the ranks of the
asgardians of the galaxy
often appearing more like odin than thor
king thor has one eye one arm and little
patience for his younger counterparts he
joins the thor of the present and the
thor of the past to help defeat gore the
god butcher and later reunites with him
in the 2019 event war of the realms king
thor remains a constant throughout jason
aaron's tenure on thor and we eventually
see the thor of the present suffer the
wounds that are old news to king thor in
june 2019 marvel announced that aaron
would conclude his time riding thor with
the four-part mini-series king thor
focusing primarily on this future
odinson so i'd like a lot of different
thors i don't think we have to pick just
one
thor wasn't always worthy of mjolnir
impatient for his chance with the hammer
the young thor is often seen testing his
ability to lift the hammer only to curse
at it when he fails without mjolnir the
youthful thor carries the powerful axe
yarnbjorn unfortunately it can't grant
thor the gift of flight like mjolnir so
instead he rides a chariot pulled by his
two flying goats
this younger ax-wielding odinson aides
the present day thor both in his battle
against the god butcher and his final
conflict with malaka in more of the
realms
in the 2018 marvel event infinity wars a
separate universe is created in the soul
stone whose inhabitants are the
combination of pre-existing marvel
characters in particular the stories of
iron man and thor merge to become that
of stark odinsen the iron hammer
almost all of the villains friends and
lovers of both thor and iron man are
combined to create the cast of iron
hammers stories madame mask and hella
for example are combined to make madame
hell
while the dark elf curse and crimson
dynamo come together as the crimson
curse
iron hammer was last seen in 2019's
secret warps event
as you can probably tell it's not
unusual for a handful of different
people to simultaneously call themselves
thor or at least to claim some of his
power but in 1993 that was still
relatively novel and that was when
marvel launched the mini-series thor
core the storyline united thor odinson
beta ray bill the original thunderstrike
and dargo the 26th century thor all on
one team the four embark on an adventure
that sees them saving reality itself and
battling villains in heroes from all
over the multiverse it would be over two
decades before the phrase thor core
became regularly heard in the comics
vernacular again and this time it was a
very different group of thors with a
much larger roster
in the 2015 event secret wars dr doom
creates a patchwork planet called battle
world with alternate reality versions of
different characters sharing the same
planet for his police force god doom
creates a new version of the thor core
which includes hundreds of thor's from
across the multiverse there are familiar
characters like ultimate thor and beta
ray bill alongside tons of new versions
like a gamora thor a lizard thor and
even a groot thor who says only i am
thor
you speak groot yes the total on asgard
it was an elective the thor's take
center stage in the mini-series thor's
during which the ultimate thor
investigates a string of serial murders
of different jane fosters across
battleworld the series ends with the
thor core joining the battle against god
doom the death of the ultimate thor and
the ultimate mjolnir appearing in old
asgard
on earth 928 in the year 2099 thor is
worshipped once more along with his
fellow asgardians thor left years
earlier in response to the corporation
alchemax stoking anti-hero rage those
who couldn't escape to different worlds
either ended up dead or quit being a
hero the church of thor and its
followers known as the thorites wait
anxiously for the return of the god of
thunder but unbeknownst to the thorites
thor and nearly all other asgardians
have already been killed
only loki survived by running and hiding
in punisher 2099 number 13 alkamax
engineers its own asgardians to act as
the true gods return to earth
cecil mcadam a janitor at the church
willingly allows the corporation to turn
him into their version of the thunder
god he's genuinely motivated by a desire
to be heroic but his corporate masters
use him to distract from their dark
dealings
when separated from his hammer mcadam
chooses to chase it into an explosion
seemingly dying rather than return to an
ordinary life
the marvel 2099 universe wasn't quite
done with thor after reverend mcadam's
demise in an echo of his silver age
return captain america was once again
discovered in a block of ice after years
of being assumed killed in the superhero
purge
around the same time alkamax located the
true hammer of thor mjolnir
steve rogers proves worthy and is able
to hoist the hammer thereby becoming a
heroic thor for the era together with
spider-man and a league of other heroes
in 2099 manifest destiny number one they
begin to repair the fallen world of
2099. this one-shot story marks the
original end of the 2099 line as it
sends the universe off on an upbeat note
marvel has typically depicted the
asgardian apocalypse of ragnarok as a
localized event readers have watched the
event destroy asgard and the gods
several times all without doing much
damage to midgard aka earth
but in what if age of ultron number
three earth is not spared
after slaying thor and destroying asgard
the monstrous serpent jormungand then
targets and kills scores of avengers
soon only a handful of heroes still live
as they decide to take on jormungand
despite the incredibly long odds
amazingly their boldness pays off by
taking the fight to jormungand the team
ends up in a position to find mjolnir
amongst the rubble and black widow then
grabs thor's abandoned hammer she's
evidently been made worthy by her time
fighting to forestall the end of
humanity and thus she can hoist the
hammer skyward and become the new god of
thunder while the book only briefly
shows her efforts nick fury's narration
confirms that she indeed carried the day
and rather spectacularly at that
i want you to meet agent romanov
x-men's rogue has been a fan favorite
for so long that newer readers might not
know that she used to run with villains
like the brotherhood of evil mutants
during that time she even took on carol
danvers and permanently absorbed her
abilities like flight and super strength
what if number 66 entitled what if rogue
possessed the powers of thor took
readers back to this era after breaking
out of prison with her fellow
brotherhood members rogue and the other
mutants find the avengers ready to put
them back in their cells rogue absorbs
the powers of thor who falls into a coma
and dies soon after now permanently
possessing the powers of a god rogue
briefly falls into cahoots with loki
persuading her to help him kill odin the
god of mischief mounts a rebellion he
sends rogue and his troops to invade
asgard and things look pretty desperate
until thor approaches rogue on the
astral plane he convinces her that she
can still be a hero regardless of her
past so she accepts her new role as the
goddess of thunder routes loki's forces
and gains acceptance from the gods and
the avengers
in the disney plus animated series what
if the episode what if thor were an only
child sees the god of thunder as an
immortal partier who can also
nonetheless still wield his hammer
without loki to make his life miserable
or inspire him to protect others he's
lived a charmed life devoid of
consequence or responsibility as such he
is a charming but reckless [ __ ] who
hops from planet to planet throwing
parties that are so intense that they
end up ravaging multiple worlds
after thor arrives on earth things
finally start to change when jane foster
helps him see the value of humanity and
captain marvel keeps his destructive
impulses focused on her in the end the
heroes of earth managed to save the
planet in a manner both silly and
logical as it turns out the best way to
stop a man-child in his tracks is by
calling his mother
yes even dc characters can be worthy of
mjolnir during the blockbuster dc versus
marvel event cosmic forces pitted heroes
from both universes against each other
after thor loses his hammer while
battling dc's captain marvel wonder
woman then comes across mjolnir she's
able to lift it and quickly absorb the
powers of the god of thunder emerging
from the lightning in a new costume
ready for a fight but when her chosen
opponent storm arrives she quickly
discards the hammer in the name of a
fair and honorable fight and promptly
gets wrecked by the mutant
considering that she's fighting for the
very existence of the dc universe it
might seem odd that wonder woman would
so quickly exceed an advantage however
it's worth noting that the results of
the crossover were based on fan voting
so perhaps the creators felt it was far
too unrealistic to give storm her fan a
firm victory over wonder woman when the
justice leaguer had both her own power
and thor's
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]